[Music]  foreign  he was stationed on a supply train that  got robbed last night only one type of  crutch I know that could fly him up  there  you think a pigs did this who else  I'm not police not anymore I can't help  you  we are a nation under attack from within  it is my duty to send a message to any  considering sedition  a gift from the chancellor to the Fine  people of the road  executed without even a child innocent  man  the world's falling apart and we can't  just sit at home and do nothing what  have you got in mind  take a closer look at what you're doing  to us  I thought if we were peaceful they'd  show us Mercy  but now we know the truth if they shoot  at US Nail our heads against a wall they  will pay for it in their own blood  if you go after them they'll come for  all of us the whole row will burn  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]